give me your insurance information right
now or I'm calling the cops okay all
right okay okay dude I'm sorry I'm sorry
that's just that's my personality I was
messing with you I apologize I thought
you're gonna take off and and flee the
scene yeah no I'm not whoa then how am I
gonna get my car fixed hey we just had
an accident it's obviously not the time
of the place of the place so I'm I'm
sorry
here you go
here it is I mean can you imagine though
yeah that you were gonna take off yeah
yeah I can't imagine that it's giving me
chills on the [__] spine
anyway
here's the real insurance card and uh
let me know what you think
official laminated license to [__] hey
I am a
so fast